hey kids Jack here sup it's time we got
real it's time we got real about the
moon super cool tip number one stay in
the air Elvis has really low gravity so
why bother taking cover when you can
just double jump into the air and kill
all the bad guys before your feet even
touch the ground and while you're up
there tip number two don't forget the
power of the slam just crouch in the air
and you'll plummet toward the ground
like a meteor bado badass and love do it
when you're above an enemy and they'll
break and feel it tip number three use
your skills I brought four of you up
here to find that ball with me so don't
be shy when it comes to violence
Wilhelm you got your drones which will
defend you or attack baddies Athena
you've got your shield which I don't
want to get soon but if you upgrade it
the right way you can use it just like
someone whose name rhymes with smash of
America
tip number four be on the lookout for
you Luke we got new guns new grenades
and hey remember that slam I mentioned
before if you get the right kind of oz
kit you can modify that slam with
elemental damage and imagine but
slamming someone so hard they exploded
acid just think about that tip number
five lasers pick they're really cool
look that guy's on fire that's funny
tip number six cryo weapons are awesome
if you freeze somebody and then punch
them or blast them they'll shatter and
that will be hilarious
listen real close when their body
explodes
we'll find a little crystals you can
actually hear her family cry anyway not
fun
you can